basically this is a romantic melodrama
in fact in most your movies are closed
yes Pan's Labyrinth Mexican melodrama is
never far away the fact is Gothic
romance which is what this movie is in
spite of it being sold as horror much
for my many vociferation you know III
think Gothic romance connected with me
at a very early age I read about when I
was about 7 years old 6 7 years old
maybe even younger I read at the same
time in the same sort of week Jane Eyre
and Frankenstein and both of them struck
me as incredible emotional
autobiographies you know and and and
that's what Jane Eyre is subtitled you
know and and I and I thought I developed
at a very early age a huge crush from
the Bronte's and Mary Shelley huge like
a groupie they were like my they were
like I was like it was like a girl band
for me I followed them and I read
everything I could about their lives you
know whatever is available and I have
since I was a child I've had any normal
sense of tragedy and an enormous sense
of you know you remember in in radio
days Woody Allen goes to the
psychologist and the mother says he says
the universe is expanding I was like
that with mortality
since I mean I dealt with that issue
since I was very very young I saw my
first body at age five five or four they
convict you no no it was a traffic
accident but it really you know when I
see flashbacks in movies they actually
happen I mean when I was a kid I kept
flashing back to that image of that
accident and and I didn't understand
that and then I understood it and I I
found in Frankenstein Jane
and much later as you know I'm a
bibliophile and a collector and an avid
reader
I found the the basic principles of
Gothic which were a counter movement to
the age of reason embracing emotion and
romance and it's the first time in any
artistic movement in in the history of
mankind where love and death come
together and I felt and that's that's my
vibe that I connected at a very young
age with that and I think there's a
poetic thing on a sense of loss and I
never celebrate wieners and I never go
with winning teams I tried to go for
even in a thing as big and loud a
specific rim I want to see oxidized
robots I want to see people losing the
battle that's what so you know yes but
I'm a lot of fun in the long ride and I
mean I'm like that in my movies I'm not
gonna go we're gonna die you can drive
ahead I just catch up with you but that
that sense of just complete tragedy and
that idea that for you the question I've
always wanted to ask you is why how do
you choose when to start a movie because
there's so much history involved in
these stories I mean they could start at
almost any point and I always wondered
for example how do you choose to start
this movie were with the girl yeah well
you know I I always I have I think I'm
in the spectrum somehow because I always
think on movies in terms of colors and
movement and music and I wanted to make
the movie almost symphonic in a
painterly way which I don't know if the
synesthesia made sense but the idea was
to open in white and end in white and
open with a black ghost and in with a
black ghost and then sort of color-coded
and make the camera and all the visual
work and and I started to feel that in
terms of images and so forth but the
main thing was to recuperate the
feminine spirit that fueled the Gothic
romance the
and that that brings a burden a huge
burden where you lose a normal audience
because you you think you take away the
fact that the ghosts are not gonna be
the billons you take any judeo-christian
sense of good and evil which is the
easiest way to scare people you know
when you say these are evil entities you
immediately have a weight this woman
killed the seven children with an axe
she appears normally dressed with an axe
you're scared but I wanted the ghost to
be the horror to be human in the same
way that the love of the movie is human
and then they construct everything while
using a very very traditional structure
because Gothic romance Jane Eyre begets
Rebecca Rebecca begets I walked with a
zombie you know even The Secret Garden
has the same and it's a journey that is
very similar to fairy tales you use a
very very traditional structure or plot
to have a shorthand with an audience you
know and you say look that's not
important the important thing is that in
Gothic romance the the idea of it had
degenerated into this paperback idea at
the airport of Fabio with a girl running
away from a burning mansion without a
shirt because Fabio never found his
shirt and and and and I wanted to solve
the mystery family thank you I wanted to
revert that and have the girl rescue
Fabio and there's when I started playing
with the things that I wanted to twist
so visually I start in the sort of
colors and movement and in the story I
say how can I screw how can I make it is
like I always say I would spend my 20
years of filmmaking doing this is not a
pipe you know is III but I it has to be
a pipe for you to say this is not a pipe
so I use very very very linear plot to
tell a good story because I think the
difference between a complex plot and a
good story is something I really pursue
I think characters is a story moments is
a story
especially on film and I think in that
way well I guess you're talking about
this I find myself thinking too and it's
really evident here and I think this in
Pan's Labyrinth it goes back to to
Chronos the idea of rooms within rooms
it's just that these rooms that never
end at some point you almost fine I find
myself wondering if these places really
exists or if these like rooms in society
the hero or the heroine psyche you know
well this is an important difference
because this is Gothic romance are not
horror in horror if you were in a
haunted house movie normally the haunted
house has a sentient moral quality like
give you if you talk about the hunting
of Hill House the house is deranged
the house is alone the house is evil you
think of the shining and the precept of
Stephen King that says evil places
attract evil people so the place is evil
whereas in Gothic romance the building
is an extension and a representation of
the psyche of the characters and
therefore production design wardrobe
colors are in themselves an extension of
that storytelling in the fall of the
House of Usher the house is an extension
of the incestuous sick relationship of
Ashura Hayes and his sister and I wanted
to capture that I wanted to make it
chorus Kate it and I I knew that Gothic
romance the way I understand it which is
Robert Stevenson's Jane Eyre before
Orson Welles shows up with the horse you
know I love this idea that you need to
also create a visual melodrama because
your actors are gonna talk in monologues
about about robbing liniment on scars
you know and you need to be supporting
them with with a heightened visual sense
and so forth